ja wir hier bei phoenix sind ja immer
darum bemüht dass sie sich selbst ein
stück wer das ganze bild machen können
interessant ist das vor allem in diesen
tagen wenn man wladimir putin hört und
sieht die worte und gesten helfen
zumindest nachzuvollziehen wie der
präsident vielleicht schicken könnte wir
zeigen daher ausschnitte aus einem
seltsamen gespräch des
uno-generalsekretärs mit vladimir putin
gestern am weltbekannten langen tisch
ist ihre besorgnis bekannte wegen unsere
militärischen sonderoperation in der
ukraine im dorf lassen nachdem die
machthabenden in kiel öffentlich ich
möchte das noch mal betonen öffentlich
erklärt haben sie seien nicht willens
das jüngste abkommen zu erfüllen
haben wir den beschluss gefasst diese
republiken als unabhängige staaten
anerkennen mit dem ziel das leiden der
einwohner zu unterbinden leider lagen
sich die menschen unsere partner im
westen dazu
dass zu übersehen und die unabhängige
republik haben sich auf uns gewendet
die militärische hilfe zu leisten und im
geiste artikel 7 ohne 50 07 der uno
stadt tun haben wir diese hilfe
gewährt
ich muss aber sagen dass obwohl die am
militärischen einsatz läuft gehen wir
davon aus
das eine vernünftige lösung auf dem
diplomatischen wege gefunden werden kann
zum beispiel während der verhandlungen
in istanbul wo sie gerade gewesen sind
sind
gewisse wichtige
fortschritte erzielt worden
im punkte
internationale sicherheit der ukraine
haben unsere ukrainischen kollegen
darauf verzichtet also diese garantien
an die
international anerkannten grenzen der
ukraine anzubinden und damit die creme
und die ost ukraine auf der klammer zu
nehmen
also unter gewissen vorbedingungen aber
nachdem dieser fortschritte erzielt
worden sind und nach unseren deutlichen
schritten
die
günstigen bedingungen für die weiteren
verhandlungen zu schaffen
wurden wir mit der provokation in butter
konfrontiert
zu dieser provokation
mit dieser provokation hat die russische
armee nichts zu tun gehabt
wir wissen wir da am werk war wir wissen
wir dass organisiert hat und eigentlich
nach
danach hat die
verhandlungsstrategie von unseren
ukrainischen partner grundsätzlich
verändert aber nicht desto weniger
laufen die verhandlungen weiter
momentan online und ich hoffe dass wir
doch
irgendwelche vernünftige resultate
erreichen werden das wollte ich im
vorfeld von unseren gesprächen sagen ich
bin sicher dass wir auch die anderen
fragen anschneiden werden und ich freue
mich auf dieser gespräche ich kann ihr
unbehagen ganz gut verstehen aber wir
müssen diese probleme lösen auf der
grundlage der dokumenten der uno wir
sind fest überzeugt
dass die verletzung der territorialen
integrität
gegen den statuten
verstößt und wir sehr besorgt wegen der
aktuellen ereignisse
russland wird es ständig vorgeworfen
dieser markierung wird nicht
durchgeführt
russland erklärt seinerseits die
korridore sind ein gerichten und wir
sind bereit diese
unübersichtliche lage innerhalb von 2-3
tage objektiv einzuschätzen und da
können wir die wenigen zu evakuieren
zunächst zu mario pohl die lage ist
wirklich unübersichtlich kompliziert
aber
[Musik]
aber eigentlich im grund der ist ganz
einfach und klar da habe ich mit
präsident erdogan gesprochen also da
gibt es keine kampfhandlungen
kampfhandlungen sind da
eingestellt worden
ein teil der ukrainischen streitkräfte
in den industrie in anderen
industriegebieten
hat sich ergeben also es geht um über
1.000
ukrainische soldaten die sich ergeben
haben
da gibt es auch die zivilisten
die
verwundeten ukrainischen gefangenen
werden die medizinische
hilfe im vollen umfang geleistet
und was das stahlwerk also angeht ist
dieses areal vollkommen abgeriegelt
und
wir
stürmen dieses gebiet nicht an und dort
werden keine kampfhandlungen
durchgeführt